but when people look at particularly
social media bring it back to that when
you see someone who you know you see
them posed in front of their mansion
with their beautiful car and they're
leaning against it with their designer
clothes on their expensive watch
you go
that's what i want
what you really want is freedom you want
freedom from your money problems right
and i think that's okay so people once
someone
can solve their money problems either by
lowering their lifestyle or by making
enough money
and you know
essentially what you want to get
everybody to the retirement but not
retirement in the i'm 65 years old
sitting in a nursing home collecting a
check retirement different definition
retirement is when you stop
sacrificing today for some imaginary
tomorrow
okay yes when today is complete in and
of itself you're retired yeah and so how
do you get there well one is you can
have so much money saved up that just
your passive income off of that without
you having to lift a finger covers your
burn rate keep your burn rate low right
a second is you just drive your burn
rate down to zero you become a monk
a third is you're doing something you
love you enjoy it so much it's not about
the money right so there are multiple
ways to that path but the most common is
people just say i need to make more
money and the kind of wealth creation
that i talk about is about creating
timeless principles and adapting
yourselves that making money won't be an
issue and you can do it by doing what
you love right like we get into this
model of i must work for other people
work my way up the ladder
i must like do what that person is doing
to make money but really today in
society you get rewarded for creative
work for creating something brand new
that society didn't even know yet that
it wanted that doesn't know how to get
other than through you so the most
powerful money makers are actually
individual brands people like yourself
or elon or kanye or oprah or trump right
these are individual brands eponymous
name brands who themselves are leveraged
like you're leveraged you have podcast
media going out to everybody that's
leveraged the podcasts work for you when
you sleep they have knowledge that
nobody else has which is your knowledge
is the knowledge of being joe rogan i
mean who else is a ufc fighter and a
commentator and a podcaster and a
comedian and you know interested in all
these things and those all these people
can't replace you um so we have to pay
you what you're worth and was i never
fought in the ufc though
oh you didn't okay sorry
um or you know you're whatever you're
you're involved in that whole scene you
just have a unique set of skill sets
um so because of this unique what i call
specific knowledge because of the
accountability that you have with your
name because the leverage that you have
through your media you're a money making
machine you're
i'm sure at this point i could make you
start over tomorrow wipe out your bank
account you'd be rich again in no time
because you have all the skill sets so
once people have those skill sets and
the beauty is the way you've done it is
you don't have any competition there's
no substitution if joe rogan were to
disappear off the air tomorrow it's not
like random podcaster number 12 would
step in and fill that thing no it's it's
just gone so the way to get out of that
competition trap is actually to be
authentic the way to retire is actually
to find the thing that you know how to
do better than anybody and you know how
to do that better than anybody because
you love to do it no one can compete
with you if you love to do it be
authentic
and then figure out how to map that to
what society actually wants apply some
leverage put your name on it so you take
the risks but you gain the rewards have
ownership and equity in what you do and
then just crank it out i think people
have to be very careful to not get
trapped along the way with
things that you can afford with your
current lifestyle like the way you're
living and the way you're earning but
they're also imprisoning you and the
fact that you are now going to have to
work this 40-hour week job in order to
get this thing that you can't afford but
now you you're settled down to this job
you have no you're not saving you're not
you're not putting things in a good
place and you're working for these
things
working for things as rewards is a real
trap that a lot of people fall into it's
the biggest one you know naseem tell
that also says that uh you know under
two great addictions heroin and a
monthly salary
right
and and that's why you can't get rich
renting out your time because even when
you start charging more and more for
your time it's a slow upgrade loop and
then you upgrade your house at the same
time your car at the same time you move
in the neighborhood you really also have
to get used to ignoring your peers
or upgrading or changing the definition
of your peers
a lot of people here who are poor here
but they would be rich if they were
living in thailand and bali and if they
have the luxury of a remotely doable job
they may want to be living there
and saving up money but the ignoring the
peers is an issue because the keeping up
with the joneses is a real phenomenon
yeah envy makes the world go around yeah
and then there's a there's another thing
that people have to avoid even allowing
their mind to think when they're hearing
what you're saying and all this
logical fantastic advice
there's these six dirty words that's
easy for you to say yeah that is a
terrible trap i mean look i grew up as a
first generation immigrant
in jamaica queens
with zero money single mom two kids
working day and night going to school
uh you know i watched dishes uh i was
kid i was working catering jobs i was
mowing lawns i was working since the age
of 11 on and off here and there um
didn't have two cents to rub together
you know
i had to borrow 400 to go to college
like literally i was short 400 dollars
400 i had to find 400 i didn't have it
um you know got rejected from a job at
dunkin donuts so like okay
it's not to say that it's easy it's not
easy it's actually really freaking hard
it is the hardest thing you will do but
it's also the rewarding thing you know
look at the kids who are born rich no
meaning to their lives you're a terrible
place yeah your real your real resume is
just a cataloguing of all your suffering
right if i were to ask you to describe
your real life to yourself when you look
back on your deathbed you're going to go
back and say what are the interesting
things i've done and it's all going to
be around the sacrifices that you made
and the hard things that you did
anything you're given doesn't matter
you know you you have your four limbs
you have your brain you have your head
you have your skin that's that's all for
granted so you have to do hard things
anyway to create your own meaning in
life
um
making money is a fine one yeah struggle
it is hard i'm not going to say it's
easy it's really hard but the tools are
all available it's all there peter thiel
talks a lot about how competition is
besides the point it's counterproductive
we're highly mimetic creatures we copy
what everybody else is doing around us
we copy our desires from them everyone
around me is a great artist i want to be
an artist everyone around me is a great
business person i want to be a business
person everybody around me is a social
activist i want to be a social activist
that's where my self-esteem will come
from
you have to be a little careful when you
get caught up in these status games that
you end up competing over things that
aren't worth competing over so peter
thiel talks about how he was going to be
a law clerk because he was in law school
and everybody around him wanted to be a
law clerk for a supreme court justice or
some famous judge and he got rejected
and that's what made him go into
business so it helped him break out of a
lesser game into a greater game so
sometimes you just get trapped in the
wrong game because you're competing and
the best way to escape competition to
get away from the specter of competition
which is not just stressful and
nerve-wracking but will often drive you
to just the wrong answer the way to
escape competition is to just be
authentic to yourself if you are
fundamentally building and marketing
something that is just an extension of
who you are no one can compete with you
on that who's going to compete with joe
rogan or scott adams it's impossible is
somebody else going to come along and
write a better dilbert no is someone
going to compete with bill waterson and
create a better calvin and hobbes no
they're being authentic
this is easiest to see in art artists
are by definition all naturally
authentic but even entrepreneurs are
authentic who's going to be elon musk
who's going to be jack dorsey these
people are authentic and the businesses
and products they create are authentic
to their desires and their means
if somebody else came along and started
launching rockets i don't think it would
phase elon one bit he's still gonna get
to mars because that's his mission you
know insane as it seems that's the one
he set for himself and he's gonna
accomplish it so authenticity naturally
gets you away from competition it
doesn't mean that you necessarily want
to be authentic to the point where
there's no product market fit it may
turn out you're the best juggler on the
unicycle but maybe there just isn't that
much of a market for that even with
youtube videos so you got to adjust that
somehow until you find product market
fit but at least lean towards
authenticity towards getting away from
competition and competition
automatically leads towards copycatting
and often towards just playing
completely the wrong game
especially in entrepreneurship the
masses are never right if you see a lot
of people tweeting about what a great
market to enter is or you see
journalists talking about a company is
terrible they don't know anything if the
masses knew how to build great things
and create great wealth we'd already be
done we'd already be rich by now so in a
sense when you see a lot of competition
sometimes that indicates to you that the
masses are already here so it's already
competed over too much and there's
nothing here or it's in the wrong trend
to begin with on the other hand if it's
completely empty if the whole market is
empty and no one's there that can also
be a warning indicator that you've gone
too authentic and not enough on the
product market fit part of founder
product market fit
so there's a balance you have to find it
but generally most people will make the
mistake of paying too much attention to
the competition and being too much like
the competition and not being authentic
enough and the great founders tend to be
authentic iconoclasts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you